[Musique]
bonsoir à tous on commence une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi
le lundi 17 juin tout de suite le
sommaire de cette édition les lois
peuvent elles faire notre bonheur le
travail difficile les hommes
voici deux sujets du baccalauréat de
philosophie proposé aux lycéens ce matin
cette année près de 80 mille candidats
passent l'examen dans les yvelines
retour sur cette matinée maternelles
primaires collégiens et lycéens danse à
l'école chaque année depuis 20 ans ce
projet piloté par la mission dense de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a présenté son année de travail
un week end ateliers et de
représentation puis retour sur un
week-end de sport dans les yvelines avec
la chronique du lundi
au programme du football avec la coupe
des yvelines du baseball et la course
royal dans le parc du château de
versailles
dans ce journal nous recevons aussi des
délégués du défenseur des droits pour
parler de leur activité dans le
département
autres invités y foucher président du
coc des skis avec une soirée débat sur
l'engagement citoyen organisé ce jeudi
veulent jeu on l'a appris dans la
matinée magalie tabareau présidente de
la cour d'assises de versailles a été
agressé à son domicile peu après 9
heures ce lundi 17 juin deux hommes
auraient sonné à la porte lui aurait
tiré à la tête avec une arme de type
flashball avant de prendre la fuite
blessé au visage la magistrate a été
transporté à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris et de son côté comme
vous le voyez à l'écran la ministre de
la justice nicole belloubet a exprimé
son émotion et son indignation
toutes les forces de l'ordre sont
mobilisés pour retrouver les auteurs fin
de citation et pour l'heure les auteurs
de cette agression sont toujours
recherchés une enquête de flagrance a
été ouverte elle a été confiée à la
section de recherches de la gendarmerie
de versailles 743 1594 candidats au bac
cette année à travers la france et comme
d'habitude ils ont débuté ce lundi matin
par l'épreuve de philosophie toutes
sections confondues
nous étions au lycée de la plaine 2 nov
la trappe pour recueillir les réactions
des lycées
un reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et wilfrid rifi selon vous le
travail difficile les hommes parce que
le travail divisé les hommes je pourrais
dire que on a deux parties oui oui et
non il travaille est difficile les
hommes n'ont pas forcément vous le
travail difficile elle les hommes si le
sujet inspire moyennement les yvelinois
ils étaient plus de 20 mille candidats
de la filière économique et sociale dans
les yvelines devoir s'y pencher ce lundi
matin lundi 17 juin l'ouverture de la
nouvelle session du baccalauréat par la
traditionnelle épreuve de philosophie
j'ai juste appris ma cour j'essaie de
comprendre parce que pour moi la
philosophie va comprendre par là qu'on
parker se sert à rien à part les
définitions on a toujours l'impression
de pas être assez préparé donc on croise
les doigts et on croit la bonne chance
parmi les autres sujets proposés elle
les lois peuvent elles faire notre
bonheur où la pluralité des cultures
fait l obstacle à l'unité du genre
humain
ce que j'ai sous les yeux c'est le sujet
ds très beau sujet vraiment ces trois
sujets j'aurais eu du banat à choisir
entre les trois sont vraiment des
les belles choses avec
des diversités fin des sujets qui sont
divers qui font appel à des références
très variés et sur lesquels je pense que
les élèves peuvent vraiment faire est
excellente copie 70 1944 candidates et
candidats se présentent dans les
yvelines au baccalauréat dont un peu
moins de 30000 dans les séries
technologiques et professionnelles et
après 4 heures d'épreuve la confiance le
dispute comme toujours au soulagement ça
s'est bien passé
actuellement ça va je pense qu'il me
suis bien débrouillé après c'est vrai
qu'on l'a appréhendé la philo ça faisait
un moment est bon la philo c'est pas
quelque chose de simple donc forcément
on a dû faire avec mais franchement je
pense que ça s'est bien passé
franchement ça va il était facile mais
mon profil m'a dit j'aurais pas plus de
8 à bond médias mais je pensais bonnes
notes 3 de la philo prochaine épreuve
l'histoire-géographie mardi matin suivis
par les langues mercredi résultats
attendus le 5 juillet à noter que le
plus jeune candidat de france se trouve
dans les yvelines
il n'a que 11 ans 7 mois et une
vingtaine de jours c'est le plus jeune
candidat de l'histoire il est inscrit en
série scientifique 82 % des habitants de
poissy ont dit non au maintien de la
prison en centre ville
c'est le résultat de la consultation
numérique lancé le 1er juin
au total près de 3400 personnes se sont
exprimées sur la plateforme digitale
cette consultation voulue par le maire
de la ville karl olive fait suite à
l'effondrement d'un mur de la prison le
28 mars dernier et à la visite de la
garde des sceaux nicole belloubet la
ministre de la justice avait promis une
enveloppe de 60 millions d'euros pour
rénover l'établissement existant karl
olive a transmis ce lundi les résultats
de la consultation au ministère nous ont
rejoints sur le plateau trois délégués
du défenseur des droits joël aunès
représentants sur guyancourt a lu faty
vous vous êtes sûr sartrouville aiguë
avenard délégué à trappes bonsoir à tous
les trois bonsoir
alors vous êtes les représentants du
défenseur des droits qui se situe au
niveau du haut niveau national c'est
jacques toubon une autorité
administrative dite indépendante son
activité défendre et promouvoir les
droits des citoyens
créée en 2008 à travers une révision
constitutionnelle son activité définie
dans l'article 71 tirs et 1 le défenseur
des droits veille au respect des droits
et des libertés alors je me tourne vers
vous a dit fathi concrètement quel est
le rôle de cette institution
effectivement le défenseur des droits
est une institution indépendante
inscrite dans la constitution depuis le
24 juillet 2008 le défenseur des droits
a succédé à quatre autorités
administratives indépendantes qui était
l'ex le médiateur de la république en
lien avec les services publics l'ex
halde lutte contre les discriminations
et l'ex défenseur des enfants qui est
axée sur le droit des enfants et
notamment à 4m compétence et l ex
d'hôtes au logis de la sécurité alors le
défenseur des droits désigne à la fois
l'institution est la personne qui la
dirige donc muscles jacques toubon
il parle souvent de l'institution
personnalisé de 2011 à 2014
c'était parce que dominique baudis et
depuis 2014 et muscu jacques toubon
vous vous êtes les relais sur le
territoire c'est ça la danse est un
réseau de proximité
le défenseur des droits un réseau de
proximité sur l'ensemble du territoire
et notamment messieurs dom tom
on est à peu près 500 quand exactement
délégué depuis 2009 et couvrons
l'ensemble du territoire et dans les
yvelines vous êtes 11 délégués répartis
dans les plus grandes communes du
département on va voir la carte
s'afficher à l'écran
plusieurs communes du département et
vous êtes aussi présent dans des maisons
d'arrêt à bois d'arcy versailles poissy
et porcheville
alors si on fait un bilan de votre
activité en 2018 vaut a reçu 1767
saisine par 1789 c'était des
orientations et des informations à
donner aux personnes qui vous
interpellez 978 réclamations déjà je me
tourne vers vous j'ai l'honneur telles
différences ont fait entre orientations
et réclama sous la réorientation
effectivement lorsqu'un réclamant se
présentent à notre permanence on étudie
la recevabilité de son dossier une
réorientation ça signifie que notre
compétentes nous ne sommes pas
compétents pour traiter de son affaire
on n'est pas compétent pour traiter son
affaire néanmoins on étudie son problème
parce que quand il vient nous voir c'est
qu'il est vraiment dans la difficulté
on a des formations pour et on peut au
moins l'aider à rédiger un courrier à
étudier son problème
et puis il y a également les réclamants
qui eux entrent dans notre champ de
compétence il faut savoir que lorsqu'un
réclamant et les personnes qui nous
regardent
s'ils veulent venir nous voir il faut
déjà qu'ils aient fait une démarche sans
démarche
on ne peut que les réorienter ils
reviendront après mais c'est essentiel
ça c'est un élément majeur pour l on
crée une réorientation une réclamation
c'est par rapport à quoi en fait
ben je viens de vous le dire c'est que
en fait souvent les gens n'ont pas fait
une première démarche sans cette
première démarche auprès d'une
administration voilà aux un service
public me fathi ben comment on ne peut
pas prendre en compte leurs demandes
ça c'est une première chose tout petit
d'administration également des domaines
d'intervention quand il y à des litiges
entre personnes privées entre une
entreprise et comment se réclamant on ne
peut pas intervenir sauf est notre
collègue git avenard il va nous parler
de la commande des domaines de
compétences et ça va mieux nous éclairer
alors justement guitare quand on parle d
administration déjà quelles sont-elles
et quelles compétences eux vous exercez
vous dans quel type de demande de vous
vous intervenez alors s'agit sein des
administrations cet outil
d'administration administrations d'état
administration des collectivités locales
services des collectivités locales et
associations ou structures ayant une
compétence de service public
donc voyez c'est très large donc on est
saisi comme l'a dit joël par les
administrés sur cinq domaines de
compétences donc le les services publics
le fonctionnement des services publics
les sujets de la discrimination les
sujets de la de défense de droits des
enfants également le sujet les sujets
concernant la dénoncer déontologie des
activités de sécurité
mais il faut savoir que je vous précise
que en fait 93% notre activité concerne
le
fonctionnement des services publics
c'est à dire c'est quel type
concrètement qu'est ce que c'est en fait
une personne qui rencontre des
difficultés à pôle emploi pour recevoir
ce sont ces indemnités de chômage une
personne qui a des qui voit ses droits
auprès de la caf supprimé du jour au
lendemain de voiliers ce type de sujet
il faut on peut noter quand même que le
service public
vous jouez pas utiliser un moule
utiliser le mot de dégrader un mais
depuis quelques années le le défenseur
des droits dans son rapport et là je
montre à l'écran c'est vous le permettez
sur le rapport 2018 donc alerte
l'opinion sur cette dégradation du
service public
ces dégradations l'esprit que de
plusieurs manières le fait que d'un
certain nombre d'activités publiques ont
été privatisées entre guillemets je vous
en prie ont été privatisés le fait qu'un
certain nombre d'activités du service
public notamment en matière sociale sont
confiés à des associations loi 1901 est
en fait les également je le dis avec mes
mots les coupes budgétaires année
appréhendait réduisent le père a mis le
périmètre des services publics tout ça
génère des difficultés vous interpeller
les pouvoirs publics sur ces questions
là justement vous êtes c'est quoi votre
rôle dans ce cadre là en fait absolument
et moi je voudrais vous donner un
chiffre c'est que comme en l'an dernier
les dossiers traités on a traité en
recourant règlement amiable 75 de 65 %
des dossiers qui nous vaut qui nous
était recevable et 70 % ont reçu
comment une médiation positive un
dernier mot avec vous a dit fathi si
quelqu'un si un de nos téléspectateurs
nous regardent aujourd'hui qui rencontra
un problème une difficulté ce soit par
rapport à une question sur les droits de
l'enfant une question sur la
discrimination ou sur les questions du
service public
quelle démarche qui doit engager comment
il peut vous contacter car c'est très
simple
par sa mairie en règle général les
mairies après les contacts délégué de
proximité et qui me disait mon collègue
monsieur on est effectivement reçoit
l'usagé c'est un tendu de 30 minutes 45
minutes sur lesquels effectivement
identifié le problème il ya deux niveaux
le premier niveau évidemment constater
s'il ya une démarche préalable de
l'usagé concernant la contestation qui
peut faire à l'égard du service public
si c'est pas le cas on l'invite à faire
cette démarche si la démarche a été
faite évidemment s'il ya des éléments
nouveaux dans la relation dans la
notification administratif et ses
éléments nouveaux n'ont pas été portés à
connaissance auprès d'administrations là
on peut intervenir pour demander à
l'administration de prendre en compte
étaient des animaux et pour modifier ou
pas la décision alors on arrive au terme
malheureusement de cet entretien pour
plus d'informations sur un site un site
internet c'est 3w défenseur des droits
point fr il va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran
je n'en désolé on n'a plus le temps par
rapport à cette émission je vous
remercie en tout cas d'être venu sur
notre plateau et puis bonne soirée à
vous et dans la perspective tout autre
sujet dans la perspective des jeux
olympiques de 2024 plus vécu organisée
ce samedi son deuxième symposium dédiée
au sport et à la santé cet événement
s'est déroulé à l ufr de santé simone
veil le thème de cette année
l'utilisation du numérique dans le sport
un reportage d'aurélie ronde et de
grégory canalis des spécialistes de
l'innovation technologique et numérique
réunies autour de médecins et de
sportifs deuxième édition à l'ufr simone
veil pour ce symposium dédiée au sport
et à la santé
il ya un lien très fort entre certaines
maladies et leurs traitements d'ailleurs
l'assurance maladie prend en charge pour
partie certains sports en prescription
et ça s'appelle
ordonnance ça c'est sûr certains sports
la marche le
l'aviron
par exemple le golf tout dernièrement en
vue des jeux olympiques en 2024
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines organise ce type de rendez vous
depuis l'année dernière nous réussissons
à mettre en place des actions
transversales qui sont très
intéressantes
effectivement pour cela nous appuyons
sur sur les enseignants chercheurs sur
les médecins de l'université sur le
service aussi universitaire de médecine
au programme pour cette journée des
tables rondes mais aussi des ateliers
plusieurs sports était à l'honneur du
vélo de l'aviron encore du golfe
ce simulateur permet notamment
d'améliorer son swing exactement comme
sur en partie de golf quand je vois ma
balle qui vole ça va permettre de voir à
la fois la vitesse de la balle la
rotation de la balle
ça va permettre de voir l' axe du club
si on est intérieur extérieur ça va
définir toutes là tout ce que le golfeur
a besoin pour s'améliorer
l'ufr de santé simone veil vous donne
d'ores et déjà rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle thématique
autour du sport et de la santé
on ouvre une page politique la
république en marche a investi ses
premiers candidats pour les élections
municipales de 2020 ce lundi 17 juin
parmi eux gilles schmitt investi tête de
la liste lrm à rambouillet le suppléant
de la députée aurore bergé conduira la
campagne électorale dans cette commune
de 26 mille habitants sur une ligne
politique plutôt centriste il était
engagé dans la majorité municipale aux
côtés du maire les républicains marc
robert avant d'annoncer son retrait en
mars dernier on reste sur un sujet
politique et plus précisément la
citoyenneté avec notre nouvel invité
yves fouchet
bonsoir président du coc des skis donc
on rappelle le conseil de développement
de saint quentin en yvelines c'est une
instance participative de consultation
pour la communauté d'agglomération alors
jeudi 20 juin à partir de 19h30 dans la
salle du conseil communautaire vous
organisez une soirée autour de
l'engagement citoyen les participants
seront invités à réfléchir sur cette
question comment va s'organiser cette
soirée alors la soirée va s'organiser
autour déjà des institutions qui
existent à disposition des citoyens nos
élus je veux parler de notre conseil de
développement qui n'est pas suffisamment
connus probablement mais aussi des
conseils de quartier mais aussi des
associations à caractère citoyen qui
peuvent exister ici où l'un est donc au
travers d'ateliers on va exprimer des
expériences ressentir vécu et puis voir
quelles sont des améliorations possibles
dans un deuxième atelier
et puis j'espère aboutir quelques
propositions pour que la démocratie
participative dont on parle beaucoup
mais qui au fond est positif peu
efficace puisse exprimer plus plus plus
efficacement comme comme l'a souhaité
présente dans le public d'ailleurs au
terme du grand débat j'allais en venir
justement la démocratie participative on
en parle de plus en plus notamment avec
le mouvement des gilets jaunes parce que
certaines revendications des gilet jaune
demandé plus de participation dans la
vie politique dans la construction de
l'action publique mais il ya aussi
l'engagement et du grand débat national
par le président de la république est ce
que ces deux événements ces deux
phénomènes vous ont poussé à organiser
cette soirée jeudi plus le grand débat
national que les gilet jaune très
clairement pourquoi parce que les
conseils de développement qui sont
réunis en coordination nationale se sont
exprimés et le codis qui s'est exprimé
sur la citoyenneté de l'amélioration de
la citoyenneté est en fait c'est cette
idée de deux plénières ouvertes de jeudi
soir si pour voir comment améliorer
faire venir aussi parce que améliorer la
relation entre le citoyen les élus est
une chose faut-il encore que les
citoyens viennent participer aux débats
viennent participer aux propositions
pour les sceptiques donc c'est
effectivement est complètement dans la
continuation du grand débat pour lancer
une réflexion dès ce soir est ce que
vous avez déjà des idées
et pour améliorer les dispositifs
existants concernant la démocratie
participative ou créer de nouvelles
institutions dans le dans ce cadre là je
pense que les outils existent
j'ai peut-être pas la peine de
réinventer encore 36 outils peut-être
faut-il donner une place une
représentativité plus significatif
justement conseil de développement dans
les agglomérations de quartier dans
l'est dans les municipalités avec des
initiatives qui ont déjà existé comme un
budget participatif
on propose aux citoyens ou aux habitants
des agglomérations
un budget est le budget est bien que
voulez-vous en fait après les élus
décident mais c'est de ce sont des
démarches en fait objective qui
permettront d'améliorer les choses je
crois les fruits de cette soirée les
réflexions de cette soirée qu'est ce que
vous allez en faire ensuite le codis qui
est une organisme qui dépend du conseil
de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines donc ce sera mis à disposition
des élus de saint quentin en yvelines
tous les élus de saint quentin en
yvelines et on verra si on peut
améliorer les choses
on a déjà émis quelques quelques idées
aussi sur la nécessité de connaître par
exemple pour les prochaines municipales
le nom des élus municipaux certes mais
aussi le nom des élus communautaires
parce que on ne sait pas tout à fait et
donc s'améliorer probablement la
démocratie également un dernier mot en
lien avec l'engagement citoyen c'est
notamment la place des jeunes dans
l'engagement citoyen on sait que les
jeunes s'approprient très peu 1 par
rapport aux autres populations à l'autre
partie de la population la vie politique
l'engagement politique
comment pourrait stimuler justement
l'engagement policier les jeunes ont
beaucoup plu voté qu'on imaginait les
sauveurs surprend tromper sélection aux
élections européennes je pense que la
jeunesse de france
elle est aussi capable dynamique active
que n'importe quel autre jeunesse
mais effectivement il faut lui présenter
des thèmes qui l'intéressent et c'est
pour ça que le code skis aussi travail
sur la jeunesse pour qu'elle reste où qu
elles viennent à saint quentin il
travaillait y vivre et améliorer la
démocratie
allons un dernier mot comme en fait pour
s'inscrire à cette soirée et bien c'est
pas compliqué vous avez sur le site de
l'agglomération il s'affiche en bas
d'écran qui doit s'afficher ski point fr
slash en garant qui rejoignent un
citoyen voir et on s'inscrit sur
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire plus on
sera et plus le débat sera riche et tant
mieux on précis c'est à la salle
communautaire de l'agglomération
absolument il foucher merci beaucoup
merci à vous président du conseil de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines
merci et direction elancourt avec ce
moment de fête et de partage à la
commanderie 20 classes du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines se sont
rassemblés pour clôturer un an de
travail et des changes sur la danse
elles ont participé tout l'eau tout au
long de l'année scolaire à danse à
l'école
un projet qui fête cette année ses 20
ans un reportage de grégory canale et
mélanie poker
une dernière danse en cette fin d'année
à la commanderie 20 classes du
territoire présenté à leur famille le
travail d'une année du projet danse à
l'école pour présenter une autre spectre
et qu'on a fait pendant un an presse on
a dansé on a parlé de la danse on a tous
fait disposé à 13h20 cieux n'a pu faire
beaucoup truqués avant j'étais petit
village rush est trop timide
un projet qui fête cette année ses 20
ans piloté par la mission dense de
l'agglomération il regroupe des élèves
de la grande section de maternelle au
lycée sur le volontariat des enseignants
elle leur permet par les ateliers par
les spectacles par la création d'être
citoyen aussi en même temps que toute la
pédagogique et développé à l'école
la danse est aussi une entrée dans les
apprentissages qui permet parfois des
enfants qui peuvent être en difficulté
de trouver un domaine dans lequel ils
peuvent s'épanouir un projet pour
découvrir la danse contemporaine en
allant voir des spectacles et en
participant à des ateliers les élèves
étaient encadrés de neuf danseurs
professionnels
j'ai toujours été intéressé par la
transmission en fait et du coup
questionner aussi comment l'art bien
raisonner avec avec l'école et qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce que la création
l'expérimentation artistique bien
construire dans chaque individu
depuis sa création le projet allait
participer près de 12000 enfants de
danse à l'école tend vers sa 21e année
[Musique]
et comme les élèves du projet danse à
l'école il est allé arrivé avec une
pirouette sur le plateau bonsoir grégory
mon soir nicolas et alors une fois n'est
pas coutume c'est vous et non michael et
demi d'euros qu'on le retrouve pour la
chronique sport et du flou
effectivement et on vous retrouve dès
demain dès demain soir à 18 heures et du
football donc pour débuter cette
chronique oui on jouait ce week-end à
verneuil sur seine la finale de la coupe
des yvelines seniors et c'est là et
c'est vélizy qui a été sacrée un score
sans appel
elles n'ont pas un deux ou trois héros
nikola mais 7-0 contre carrière à
grésillons une grosse raclée infligée
vous allez voir peut-être ce coup franc
dans un instant le voici ce coup franc
parfaitement exécuté il va être tirée
vous allez le voir nicolas dans la
lucarne droite du gardien de carrière
grésillons un magnifique coup-franc
troisième coupe des yvelines de
l'histoire de vélizy qui aura fait
mentir la hiérarchie puisque en
championnat l aider lysiens évolue une
division plus bas que carrière
grésillons des nouvelles des cougars de
montigny le bretonneux un oui nos
joueurs de baseball favori en tout cas
ceux de notre territoire il jouait ce
week-end la 10e journée en retard de
division à domicile victoire 5-1 dans la
première rencontre contre le puc paris
avant de s'incliner 2 à 1 dans le match
de lésigny montain terminent donc
deuxièmes du groupe b est 2è de d1 les
cougars forts de leur troisième place
vous le voyez à l'image obtenue le week
end avant à la s7 cup la petite coupe
d'europe de baseball qui se jouait en
république tchèque
et bien c'est couillard ils seront en
déplacement nicolas le week-end qui
arrive les 22 et 23 juin pour la journée
une des playoffs ce sera sur le terrain
de rouen et si vous avez suivi
l'actualité sportive rouen montini ce
n'est autre que la revanche de la
dernière finale de division 1 perdu l'an
passé par les signé monte
ce sera l'occasion d'avoir une revanche
alors pour terminer on courait au
château de versailles
mais ils tiennent édition de la go sport
running dans le parc du château il y en
avait pour tous les goûts
parcours de 15 km pour les plus aguerris
et puis des courses plus courtes
l'événement se voulait avant tout festif
comme le rappelle sa marraine
et ancienne miss france et je crois que
c'est vous le chanceux du jour nicolas
c'est vous qui l'avait interviewé c'est
le sport accessible à tous à tous les
niveaux à tous les âges
et c'est une course conviviale aussi au
delà de ça les gens se déguise voilà les
gens ont le sourire
il n'y a pas forcément de recherche de
performance on est là pour se faire
plaisir et et c'est ma vision du sport
aujourd'hui à plus de 160 mille coureurs
étaient de la partie pour cette huitième
go sport une ligne merci beaucoup
grégory et puis on la suite des
événements et des résultats sportifs
dans le 7-8 sport il sera notamment
question du tournoi 17 de coeur vous
avez rencontré notamment patrice
lagisquet tout à fait avec son
entraîneur de biarritz ancien
international français est aussi
entraîneur adjoint de l'équipe de france
c'est tout de suite après à la fin de
cette édition qui se conclut maintenant
merci de nous avoir suivis donc comme je
voulais dire tout de suite le 7-8 sports
présenté par grégory canale et il fera
son retour demain aux commandes du 7-8
journal excellente soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]